turning now to our other top story
tensions rise in between the White House
and congressional Democrats who are now
threatening Trump officials with
contempt the House Judiciary Committee
set to vote tomorrow on a contempt
citation against Attorney General Bill
Barr Democrats are demanding that bar
handover an unredacted version of the
Moller report and call starting for
Treasury Secretary Stephen Venusian to
be held in contempt for refusing to hand
over the president's tax returns
meanwhile the administration is ordering
former White House Counsel dawn McGann
not to comply with a congressional
subpoena for documents related to the
Russia investigation and all of this
comes as a new report says get this
House Democrats are threatening to
withhold salaries of Trump
administration officials if they block
ongoing committee investigations despite
claims of overreach from Republicans
Democrats are defending their multiple
probes as members of Congress we have a
responsibility to oversee what this
White House and this administration is
doing and I can only hope that as the
months go by that the American people
will wake up to the fact that our
democracy is in danger
so our leader says let's move on it's
sort of like Richard Nixon saying let's
move on at the height of the
investigation of his wrongdoing of
course he wants to move on he wants to
cover up we're about getting the truth
to the American people the truth is what
we want to base our decisions on and the
administration should be willing to
share that unless they have something to
hide and you've got the media blasting
Republicans for defending the president
you look at Barr you look at Pompey he
has now surrounded himself with the most
duplicitous
cabinet and in recent American history
it is it's shameful they want a
one-party state that is what the GOP
seeks and Trump wants to be an autocrat
with that state behind it how is it that
the Republican Party your colleagues can
stand by this man when he is involved in
this way with this with Russia I mean
you know I've said last week that I
don't want to see any of those flag pins
anymore on Republicans who don't stand
up against this guy for Russian meddling
and other things that he's done it seems
as though he's on patriotic where to
even begin Greg Gutfeld let's go to you
McConnell today the spoke for the first
time really give a long speech and said
case closed in addition to move on and
then it was funny to watch Chuck Schumer
complain about that because move on
comes from moveon.org
which came from the whole point of
moving on from the Clinton scandals you
know the Dems are desperate they're like
a tiny little army faced with a
dwindling patch of turf to defend
because remember how big the threat was
a couple years ago
Trump was insane he was racist these are
the threats of world safety in the
economy now you've got the greatest
economy in 50 years low unemployment
what do they have wouldn't they clinging
to tax returns and their feelings are
hurt over the Moller report which they
asked for and they got by the way if
you're gonna scream about coverup and
conspiracy stick to stuff like JFK or
space aliens not something that's
publicly available it's really hard to
call cover-up when something is publicly
available you morons know this reminds
me of Iran's me growing up watching the
Harlem Globetrotters play the Washington
Generals right Trump is the Harlem
Globetrotters and the media and the
Democrats are the Washington Generals
they can only respond helplessly against
this strange phenomenon that continually
wins and they never adjust or adapt to
play against the Harlem Globetrotters
because they just lose every time
imagine a group of people cultists who
demand that you adhere to their
delusions or they will punish you that's
what's going on right now they are
demanding you the media the view all
these morning what's its face are
basically belonging to a pagan religion
in which they adhere to some kind of
emotional belief
that goes against all the facts low
unemployment among minorities among
women you've got GDP you got the stock
market moving up even though it drops
every now and then you got a great time
priest peace and prosperity but their
pagan cult religion means house it has
them telling everybody the world's going
to hell and even speaker Pelosi today
said that look Trump is trying to goad
us into impeaching him she clearly
doesn't want to do it but she might get
pushed into it I also I'm just reading
here that interior Commerce and Justice
Department staff of course that's
executive branch Jessie they're warned
they will have their salaries withheld
if they block ongoing committee
investigations I've been through it in a
lot of these disputes I never heard of
that the Republicans didn't think about
that in Benghazi those are some brass
knuckle tactics you gotta give the
Democrats credit I mean this is
political warfare why can't we withhold
their salaries by the way I think that
should also be an option because they've
lied for two years about the
presentation with all trumps oh wait
that's a take one he donates it to the
exact apartments that people are trying
to work for so here's what's happening
now Nadler is like a peeping tom it's
gotten creepy now he's peering through
the windows he's looking at people's
Diaries rummaging through the garbage at
that point it just gets sick and he
looks weird
and right now Muller spent what two
years looking for something didn't find
a crime the Democrats can't accept the
results of the Muller report just as
they can't accept the results of the
2016 election the bottom line is Dana is
this without collusion the scandals not
sexy you don't have dead bodies you
don't have sex you don't a bribery you
don't have video you have anything
compelling you know it's right now it's
contempt right you can't to Congress
perfect contempt attempted obstruction
executive privilege the American people
that are the appetite for that time
scandal they can only digest so much I
don't even think the American people
know who done began is I think I went
outside in the street I asked ten people
who William bar is less than half would
know who he is so right now we have a
new Q poll Quinnipiac one now opposes
impeachment by a thirty seven point
margin seventy percent of independents
are against the idea but the Democratic
base they want they want it so they
another constitutional crisis so they
have to hook up a new crime after the
investigation found nope there was
another new poll one I'm kidding I never
do that to you a Gallup poll though this
was interesting it shows he's more
popular than ever before this is the
number now 46% and that hits our I think
beats where President Obama was at this
time in his presidency yeah we went over
this yesterday we weren't here yesterday
remember but I think that's good news
for President Trump I mean obviously
he's still underwater but you know the
question is you know who's moving in
those polls what we see actually as
independents aren't moving slight
movement among Democrats did move no
they did yes it did okay let's not argue
because I just think the facts are
pretty clear 31 no okay all right the
point is that when you have what Greg is
talking about is a cult I think to
myself who won the last election terms
of popular vote I think it was a
Democrat right now most Americans don't
approve to cite the poll of trumps
behaviors present United States more
popular than Obama this time at the
economy up their heat this guy still
can't get a majority of Americans to
approve of his conduct that number 46 is
dagan I think higher than both what
Hillary and Trump were as candidates
like neither of them ever like broke 243
I don't think and his approval rating on
the economy is much higher because again
this country is so prosperous right now
and wages are growing we can get into
this later wages are growing faster for
production workers say if you work in
mining or retail your wages are growing
faster than even supervisory jobs guess
what that does it closes the wealth gap
yeah from a low level the wages are
going the fastest pace in a decade that
is not something that President Obama
could ever do decade I want to add one
thing though okay he brought up Hillary
Clinton how all right let's talk about
Hillary and we're thankful that she's
not the president United States and have
to listen to that every day number one
and number two in terms of all these TV
talk show hosts how close are we to one
of them having a Regan MacNeil moment
where
they are just so enraged and full of
bile that they just spew pieces all over
the audience and then they will
understand how we feel having to watch
these clips every day all right can I
just follow up though on the whole
business about the war because I think
there's a big war going on between White
House and Congress all these documents I
think it's very interesting when you you
know whether people know who don McGann
is or not obviously he was the White
House lawyer that was brought in by
Muller and apparently said to Muller
that Trump and the president right so
but now the White House is saying we're
not going to let you have the documents
that McGann had and you think to
yourself well how's that possible
because some of this is as you point out
already in a report that's largely been
made public some of its redacted some of
the underlying documents have been kept
secret but McGann's there so I don't
know how you then go on to claim
something I can executive privilege to
me the logic doesn't make sense it looks
like the president is hiding something
he's acting like a guilty man election
saying that you ran for two years yes on
this issue but I'm really excited is
that CNN is gonna have a Comey Town Hall
and why is that necessary why would you
have a Town Hall katak with James Comey
ah to keep it alive you've got to keep
it alive because if the profit motive
for CNN and MSNBC is always going to be
conflict and because they've betrayed
their audience with the lie of collusion
they have to keep that it's like their
except they're at a bar that's running
out of booze so now they have watered
down booths so Comey is there
watered-down booze that they're feeding
to their eyeballs who are so pissed off
that it didn't work out that way
so this is it's actually it's not about
Congress it's not about a battle between
Congress and Trump it's the polarity
between media and America the media is
so upset that this narrative collapse
what do you say to then when Chris Rea
the FBI director testifies today gee I
didn't see anything there's no evidence
of any spine that I Wow